welcome to the google cloud tech youtube  channel where we're right there with you  on your cloud journey one video at a  time  whether you're looking into starting a  new career in google cloud or if you're  a seasoned engineer and want to learn  more on how to build a google cloud this  channel is for you  we'll keep you up to date on all of  google cloud's latest announcements and  product launches  give you a sneak peek behind the scenes  like this one of a data center or how we  lay down subsea cables  interested in machine learning and ai to  help solve environmental issues  we've great content about that too or  let us take you out to the ball game for  a look into how major league baseball  uses google cloud to power their data  and analytics  we are here to support you with  everything you need to start your next  big project on google cloud  subscribe to the google cloud tech  channel today and join our community to  learn what google cloud can do for your  journey